Marshall plan it is the largest
assistant measure in American history
and it is going directly in the pockets
of hardworking taxpayers their families
and small businesses for everyone
affected by this virus we will be your
voice for those battling the virus are
lost your job or do not know if you'll
have one a month or two from now I want
you to know we're listening we hear you
and we are working for you I want to
give leader McConnell a lot of credit
from the beginning he was committed to a
bottom-up bipartisan and bicameral
process he honored his commitment and it
shows the Senate passed this bill by a
unanimous vote every Republican every
Democrat it is bold
truly bipartisan and targeted to achieve
the mission at hand our top priority is
to keep Americans at work so we aim the
efforts to keep Americans employed
through two measures for small
businesses and nonprofits the bill
provides 100% federally guaranteed loans
for eight weeks if that loan is used to
pay your employees or pay your rent or
pay your utilities it's no longer alone
it's a grant because we know what
government has asked you to do other
business gets a retention credit to keep
employees on if unfortunately American
workers find themselves out of work this
bill offers an additional 13 weeks of
unemployment insurance and dramatically
expands eligibility it also makes
benefits more generous by adding another
$600 across-the-board payment through
the end of July the Care Act's
also expands unemployment insurance to
cover gig workers and self-employed and
nonprofit employees additionally for
American families that might need a
little extra support you will start
receiving and seeing those checks
in three weeks you won't have to wait
four months for financial help payments
will be as much as twelve hundred
dollars for an individual pack payer and
five hundred dollars per child finally
this legislation provides critical
resources to American health care
workers and hospitals over one hundred
and forty billion dollars in
appropriations to support our health
systems we don't just talk about a
respect for the medical heroes among us
we are going to give them the equipment
to save lives and there are tools they
need to protect themselves the reason
for this legislation is to protect
American workers protect American jobs
and protect hard-working American
taxpayers we are providing targeted
temporary and timely relief to Main
Street not Wall Street we are not
underwriting bad business practices or
priming the pump ultimately we are
laying the foundation for a rapid
economic recovery this bill is not only
a rescue package it is a commitment a
commitment that your government and the
people whom you elected to serve we'll
do everything we can to limit the harm
and hardship you face both now and in
the foreseeable future
it's an American public if you do you
your part I promise we will do ours
mr. speaker as I said earlier it is our
responsibility to act to put aside our
differences and do what's right for the
American public aid must be robust rapid
and resilient just like it's reason just
like its recipients we are going to help
Americans through this we are going to
do this together
and in the end we are going to be
healthier stronger and more United than
ever before because as Americans that's
who we are I yield back
Jenning yields back the gentleman from
Texas reserves the gentleman from
Maryland is recognized Speaker I yield
30 seconds to mr. Cohen from Tennessee
the gentleman from Tennessee is
recognized for 30 seconds
Thank You mr. speaker words above the
speakers had at the top of this chamber
from Daniel Webster he says may in our
day and generation may we not perform
something worthy to be remembered today
is we have something worthy before us
and something to be remembered we should
all vote aye I am here to vote aye and
to encourage the President to use the
defense production act for everyone and
to continue talking to the president of
China because this is a worldwide
pandemic and yield back the balance of
my time
gentleman yields back gentleman from
Maryland reserves gentleman from Texas
is recognized gentleman reserves
gentleman from Maryland is recognized
mr. Speaker I now have the privilege of
yielding to the speaker of the house who
has been so critical in putting this
piece of legislation together and
focusing on workers and families I yield
to Speaker Nancy Pelosi of California
the speaker of the house is recognized
thank you very much mr. speaker
I thank the distinguished Democratic
leader mr. Hoyer for yielding and for
the manner in which he has enabled so
many of our members to participate in
this debate today Thank You mr. Hoyer
for your leadership on the legislation
and also for leading us today and I
thank mr. Brady for his leadership as
well for facilitating this conversation
and I thank you mr. speaker for keeping
us reasonably on time as much as
possible for congressional members thank
you for the strengths of your authority
as Speaker Pro Tem
to day I thank all of our members for
their participation on both sides of the
aisle for the seriousness which we which
we have all taken this important
challenge mr. speaker last week His
Holiness Pope Francis said
his world prayer he said enlighten those
responsibilities for the common good so
that they might know how to care for
those entrusted to their
responsibilities that is His Holiness is
quote and that is the responsibility
that we all have today as we have all
acknowledged our nation faces and
economic and health emergency of
historic proportions
due to the corona virus pandemic the
worst pandemic in over 100 years as I
proceed with my remarks I want to say to
our colleagues who are watching this the
proceedings from their chambers in the
house to come forward and come to the
come to the gallery and listen from here
so that when the time comes we will be
prepared to proceed mr. the
distinguished leader on the Republican
side mr. McCarthy and mr. Hoyer have
sent a communication to all of you to
that effect but it's very important that
you come now
the sooner you come the shorter my
remarks will be and I want to thank mr.
McCain Bush leader on the Republican
side for his leadership throughout all
of this to achieve a bipartisan
legislation and to do so as
expeditiously as possible in the house
in the house so that the message will be
clear to the American people that
whatever concerns we may have and
whatever we want to do next right now
we're going to pass this legislation and
that is because so many American
families have been touched by this
crisis more than 280 2,000 Americans so
far have fallen sick a number certain to
surge as testing goes for it and which
is already the most in the world we've
gone past China and Italy more than
1,200 Americans have tragically died
gives you chills just to think of it
millions of workers are losing their
paychecks including more than as has
been mentioned on both sides of yow 3.2
million Americans who filed for
unemployment last week alone a
staggering the court record shattering
figure countless health care workers
first responders and others fighting on
the frontlines in this crisis our great
personal risk the American people
deserve a government-wide visionary
evidence-based response to address these
threats to their lives and their
livelihood and they need it now
again I acknowledge the bipartisanship
on which we bring this legislation to
the floor last went late Wednesday night
as the leader acknowledged the Senate
unanimously passed legislation which
transformed a in our view since you
acknowledged Senator McConnell either
mcconnell i won't acknowledge our
distinguished chairman on our side which
they transformed a republican corporate
focused bill into a democratic workers
first focus and we salute we salute our
chairs that working in a bipartisan way
and in a bicameral way across the aisle
and across the capitol we were able to
dramatically expand unemployment
insurance and over defeated attempts
only the senate side to call back the
$600 per week added benefits that would
provide essential relief to the record
number of Americans losing their jobs
and I salute our chairman Richie Neal
and Bobby Scott for the work that they
did on this I know this is the work of
Ways and Means Committee and
successfully achieved full direct
payments for workers this is so
important ensuring that working-class
American families will be eligible to
receive as much as $3,400 for a family
of four I thank again mr. Neal and
Congress madam chair of the Financial
Services Committee Maxine Waters who
both of them had bigger proposals but
nonetheless advocating for all this and
by the way
I would suggest and instead of saying
it's going to take a few weeks for the
checks to get there that the
administration electronically transfer
those direct payments immediately we
ensured in the bill that any taxpayer
dollars given to industry goes first and
foremost to workers workers paychecks
and benefits not used to pay CEO bonuses
stock fund buybacks or dividends in the
rest and and I think and we have secured
a bus special oversight that will hold
the administration accountable for this
and I thank the distinguished chair of
the where to go energy the
infrastructure and transportation
committee mr. DeFazio for his leadership
in that regard I will not try to find
all of you because you may be in the
gallery as we are encouraging members to
come oh here we go
and we're also proud again I want to
salute the congresswoman waters for the
work or the holding the having the
oversight provisions in the bill for the
accounts that is going to be spending
money out we're also proud to have
secured truly historic investment of
hundreds of billions of dollars in
health hospitals health system state and
local governments ensuring that they had
the tools they needed to combat the
virus I salute chairman pallone Congress
a chair woman loi of the Appropriations
Committee and chairwoman the DeLauro for
making so much of all of that possible
and when we talk about state and local
government I want to express pride in
our own governor Gavin Newsom he was on
the front line of attacking this as well
as my own mayor breed who has
disciplined us to shelter in place for
small businesses Thank You congresswoman
madam chair Velazquez and working in a
bipartisan way we weren't fast relief
for those in need including by securing
10 billion dollars for SBA emergency
grants of up to $10,000 and making
payroll cost rent mortgage interest and
utility cost eligible for SBA loan
forgiveness and for the first time we
have
from the SBA and thanks to secretary
minuchin he is facilitating this by not
just all of the the loans going through
the SBA but going through banks with the
SBA imprimatur which makes this all go
much faster for our students we passed
payments for pause payments for federal
student loan borrowers pause the
payments and suspended wage guard
garnishment and negative credit
reporting during this time for that and
for so many other things relating to our
students I thank Bobby Scott our
chairman of energy education and
workforce and labor and for our veterans
you heard earlier all of these chairmen
make these presentations for our
veterans we secured nearly twenty
billion dollars in funding to improve
the A's readiness with equipment tests
an additional care as as 571 veterans
and 170 85 employees have now tested
positive and I thank chairman Takano and
others on the committee for their
leadership for homeowners renters and
homeless creditors again I think and
consumers I thank chairwoman waters for
her leadership there since the beginning
of this crisis we have fought to ensure
that our nation's response puts families
first as we go through this so the first
two bills that we worked in a bipartisan
way on were about addressing the
emergency the first bill was about
testing testing testing to ensure that
everyone in the country would have
access to free testing among other
things that had in there issues that
relate to and research for vaccine
research for a cure but many other
things addressing the emergency in the
second bill which also focused on the
emergency we have mask mask mask and
many other provisions focused on the
emergency but taking us to this bill
today which is about mitigation as their
distinguished mr. DeFazio would said
first we had emergency then we have
mitigate
doesn't mean we're finished with
emergency but it's moving on to
mitigating for some of the economic and
health damage caused by this pandemic
next we will move to recovery and
hopefully that will be soon always
though addressing the emergency and the
mitigation are needed how we're coming
mr. leaders I would come in with her our
gallery as we have all said universally
and we say it almost all the time that
we come to the floor no bill is perfect
no bill is perfect but we want to make
sure that at least comes near a part of
the way to being sufficient I do think
that we should and when we're
considering a bill appreciate for what
is in the bill rather than judge it for
what is not in the bill but we do know
that we must do more there's been a
constant communication among all of our
members I'm sure on both sides of the
aisle when you're at home or here with
doctors health care providers laborers
small businesses nonprofits faith groups
and scientists on the daily needs and
developments in your communities the
on-the-ground reports and clear-eyed
thinking we have are essential to in
crafting crafting our approach to all of
this so again listening to members on
both sides of the aisle and your
comments here today as well as the input
that you have been giving in the
legislative process we know that this
cannot be our final bill yet this bill
again is in the I think Bobby Scott
called it a down payment will advanced
we must advance a fourth bill to address
the continued needs for our fight
against the corona virus our state and
local governments will need vastly more
support for preventing preparing for and
responding to the crisis our hospitals
and health systems still need vast
infusions of funding so they can treat
those in need we must do more for our
health
workers and this has been a current
theme on both sides of the aisle our
gratitude for our healthcare workers
they are heroes we were thankful and
grateful to them we pray for them but we
need to do more for them than justice
say those words our frontline health
care workers and whether emergency needs
our firefighters are law enforcement or
face a dire lack of medical and personal
protective equipment PPE personal
protective equipment that's the
reference that when you see PPE that's
what it is we must ensure that the
president uses the defense to production
act to its full extent to provide the
tools that we need to combat this crisis
all workers are risking their lives on
the front lines of this fight and need
stronger OSHA protections to keep them
safe Thank You mr. Scott this week for
example for example and you probably all
have examples this week we learned of
the tragic death death of Chios Kelly a
nurse manager in New York who died in
the line of duty from coronavirus he and
his fellow nurses risks their lives
without proper protective equipment
because the hospital supply simply did
not have enough nurses were given a
single plastic protective gown to use
for an entire shift when protocol called
for a change of gowns between
interactions with patients other nurses
were forced to resort to tying bandana
bandanas over their faces in place of
proper equipment and still others even
began tying plastic garbage bags around
disposable scrubs that they were given
in place of proper scrubs for extra
protection as mr. Kelly's sister said
his death could have been prevented I'm
angry he was healthy and now our nurses
doctors health care workers and first
responders
need action we have to make sure they
know that help is not on only on the way
but it is a priority for all of us these
people risk their lives trying to save
other people's lives and then they take
home what they enacted interacted with
in an infected environment take home
this is just asking far too much our
families our workers our retirees still
need more money in their pockets to
protect their income security with
increased snap we one thing we couldn't
get in the bill was the increase to the
15% increase in in food stamps for our
children for our seniors for those who
qualify bigger direct payments I hope
that will be an agreement I know that
Ritchie and Maxine had the idea of
ongoing direct payments so bigger direct
payments pension protections we had a
protection in the legislation it was
supported by everyone the President of
the United States supported it but
Senator McConnell said he would save it
for the next bill so that's why I'm
mentioning it for the next bill and then
we need more expanded Family and Medical
Leave
let me give you an example come on my
colleagues to the gallery let me give
you an example if your parent is sick
but had ongoing caregiver in the home or
went to a senior health center on a
daily basis and because of the virus
that caregiver couldn't come or that
health center was closed you would be
able to give you would be able to take
family and medical aid however as in the
case of many members here if your mom or
your dad are healthy and they contract
the coronavirus you would not be able to
take family and medical leave what we
would like that to say is for those who
cannot care for themselves you it just
doesn't make any sense in my view so in
any case we need that and without
exception and
all Americans need free coronavirus
treatment so they don't have to fear the
high cost of a hospital stay and others
when we said that the tests were free it
didn't mean it's the test is free but
your visit to the doctor is not it's not
and so in the days and weeks to come
Democrats will continue to advance
legislation to meet the urgent needs of
all affected by the corona virus and I
keep saying the cornerbacks because in
this bill people said well how come we
didn't do this or that because this is
specific to the corona virus challenge
that we have I just want to say a word
about our children as I close so many of
our children I want them if they are
paying attention distinguished
congresswoman Brooks mentioned the
children we're so sad for them that they
cannot be fully engaged in school as
they were some have access to remote
learning and the rest and it's had this
has had a deep impact on American life
as it affects our children as well when
I I see that some graduations have been
have been canceled and hopefully not so
many more if we can get through this and
they and I've been here as a mother of
five grandmother of nine personally but
officially and my leadership role I have
seen hundreds of thousands of graduates
and what's exciting about it personally
and officially is to see the excitement
of the families when there's child
graduates but when that family happens
to have someone on the stage who was the
first in the family to graduate the
pride the joy the patriotism all of it
is so exuberant and many of them will be
deprived of that experience of seeing
that child walk across the stage so
let's try to get this if we had the best
minds working 24/7 all hands on death to
find a cure let's make sure that that we
give them the resources they need to do
so but at the same time that we obey the
science that says shelter in place or
whatever it happens to be so as we go
let us pray let us remember what His
Holiness told us what he told us was
that we have a responsibility for the
common good so let us prepare for all
the loved ones who have lost family
members and others who are struggling
with struggling with the illness now
let's pray for our heroic health care
workers and first responders who are
risking their lives to care for the sick
every day the men and women in our
factories making more medals medical
supplies and personal protective
equipment the farmers producers and
grocery workers keeping food on the
shelves our truck drivers postal work so
everybody who is contributing to the
effort and the scientists as I say all
hands on deck 24/7 for a solution
Congress must show the same courage same
resilience same strength and was a great
unity and urgency to put families and
workers first let me again thank
everyone who had anything to do with
this and that means almost everybody in
this room let me thank the Senate
Democrats and leader Schumer for his
work as you acknowledge leader McConnell
and let us again return to the words of
His Holiness Pope Francis may we
enlighten those responsible for the
common good so that they may know now to
care for their those entrusted to their
responsibilities with that I hope we
have the biggest possible vote for the
American people to show them that
Congress's heart and the country's heart
is full of love for the American people
and with that Mr Speaker I yield back
the balance of gentlelady yields the
gentleman from Maryland reserves and the
gentleman from Texas is recognized
gentleman from Texas is recognized Thank
You mr. Speaker I I have no other
speakers and prepared to close gentleman
is recognized
thank you I yield myself as much time as
I may consume thank you thank you
McCarthy for your strong and relentless
leadership thank you for allowing each
of us to bring to the table the
pro-growth policies that brought about
the strongest economy on the planet as
we headed into this challenge thank to
our house leaders to our ranking members
and all the key committees
representative Granger's and Foxx
representatives Walden McHenry Cole &
Chabot decent members here today who
engaged in this historic agreement and
to the professional teams who evac'd us
every moment night and day in this
endeavor I want to thank our Democratic
colleagues for working with this on this
bipartisan bill to our Republican
colleagues in the Senate I especially
want to thank secretary minuchin the
point man for president Trump on these
negotiations as well as all of the
cabinet the White House economic team
and I especially want to thank President
Trump for his strong and
results-oriented leadership at a time of
unprecedented crisis for this great
country in times of challenge I lean on
this proverb fear knocked faith answered
no one was there
coronavirus has knocked at America's
door and with it fear faith is answering
we answer with faith in ourselves and
our abilities faith in our free
enterprise system faith in our amazing
health care system and yes faith that
when the chips are down Congress can
come together with our president to help
hard-working families and businesses
when they need it most
we answer that door at this crucial
moment with faith in our Creator and
faith in our great American spirit this
is the challenge of a lifetime but if we
keep pulling together we pass this bill
today without delay we take another step
toward that day when we answer the door
and fear is no longer there on behalf of
President Trump in the Republican
Congress we urge support for this bill
and I yield back
gentleman gentleman from Texas yields
back the balance of his time
the gentleman from Maryland is
recognized it's faced many threats some
in the nature of attack by enemies some
in the nature of natural disasters
whether they be hurricanes or tornadoes
or floods and Americans have responded
and overcome those threats we now have a
threat that some have mentioned that is
unseen but has a great effect and is
having a great effect today as we debate
this bill in America and today we'll
vote not as Democrats or Republicans
move voters Americans who have been sent
here to represent our country and our
people to promote the general welfare
certainly the general welfare has been
put at risk by this virus we have in a
very short time passed three major
pieces of legislation two that generated
in this house one generated in the
Senate and we will pass this bill today
I want to thank the majority leader
excuse me in the minority live in the
majority later right
you can't have it and while we while we
enjoy a little levity we understand the
gravity of this situation people will
die today as a result of this virus and
we have come together as Democrats and
Republicans from every region of this
country to respond in a way sufficient
for the challenge
and we know we'll need to do more but
this day let us hope that like the
United States Senate we come together
each and every one of us not for
partisan advantage but for the advantage
and defense of our people America has
been blessed by God and by our people
let us respond this hour to their need
in their defense so that America will go
forward stronger and better and more
ready to face future challenges mr.
Speaker I yield back the balance of my
time
gentleman yields back the balance of his
time
all time for debate has expired pursuant
to House Resolution 9 1 1 the previous
question is ordered on the motion the
question is on adoption of the motion
those in favor say aye those opposed say
no the eyes have it mr. speaker for what
purpose does gentleman seek recognition
Mr Speaker I came here to make sure our
republic doesn't die by unanimous
consent an empty chamber and I request a
recorded vote
a recorded vote is requested those
favoring a recorded vote will rise and
remain standing until counted
an insufficient number having risen a
recorded vote is refused a gentleman
recognized I object on the basis that a
quorum is not present and make a point
of order that a quorum is not present
the chair will count for a quorum and
for a quorum a quorum is present the
motion is adopted
without objection a motion to reconsider
is laid upon the table
pursuant to section 7 B of House
Resolution 891 the house stands
adjourned until 3:00 p.m. on Tuesday
March 31st 2020
[Applause]
you